في ليله الاخيره من العام 2022 اعلن الجيش
اللبناني عن وفاه امراه وطفله خلال عمليه
انقاذ 232 راكبا كانوا علمتني قارب جديد
من قوارب الموت
لكن الصدفه هذه المره جاءت ان ينقلب السحر
على المهرب لتكون واحده من الضحايا والدته
التي حاول تهريبها الى ايطاليا
هو السوري الجنسيه يدعى ابو رامي الحرزاوي
متوار عن الانظار منذ اكثر من عام
حول الوصول الى افراد عائلته الذين نجوا
من الرحله
توجهنا الى مكان السكنهم في جبل البداوي
في طرابلس
كثيرون هنا نفهم معرفتهم بالمهرب ورفضوا
الظهور امام الكاميرا
لم يتمكنوا من المشاركه في مراسم الدفن
رافضا بدوره التصوير
حضرتك
اللاجئون السوريون من عمليات التسليم
ناشطين معارضين الى النظام السوري وهو سبب
دفع وليد للمشاركه في رحله الموت الاخيره
يتفاجا بعد نجاته ان الجيش اللبناني اقتضى
الناجين السوريين الى الحدود مع وادي خالد
ليسلمهم الى الفرقه الرابعه التابعه لجيش
النظام
وادي خالد الرابعه
[موسيقى]
يسلمون الجهات امنيه السوريه
فبعمليه حسابيه بسيطه يكون ابو رامي قد
تقادى اكثر من مليون ومئتين الف دولار عن
رحله الموت الاخيره اغنيه يتيم العربيه
طرابلس